how does it feel to be part of young
Hollywood I feel like you guys signify
young Hollywood it's just so much fun to
be here and see all our friends very
exciting news miss Ariel right here what
is playing that role mean to you Wow it
means so much to me I just I feel very
honored and really grateful for the
opportunity you know Ariel was one of my
favorite princesses growing up so it's a
very dream come true so I'm very excited
and happy yeah what do they mean to you
to see her getting to do this it means
absolute world to me
my sister is so incredibly talented and
I can't wait for the world to see what I
see every single day and I'm just so
proud of her and it's gonna be really
good what have they told you about the
look the feel what do you know I just
know that it's gonna be very amazing and
beautiful and just gonna yeah are we
doing red hair I know you guys are very
close with Beyonce and she used to the
voice of Nala did you talk this through
with her at all you know I think it's so
beautiful because she allows us to
flourish on our own and I'm so proud of
my sister for taking this part
making it our own and I'm really excited
who would you rather have kissed a girl
Harry Styles mr. Ascher angel or jordan
fisher i think that anyone would be
grateful yeah
what about eat yourself others rumors
about that I mean he awesome yeah
Melissa McCarthy he's great as well
she's through hinted to us that it would
be a pretty big honor to play that wrong
have you met any of them yet I can tell
you are we gonna get original songs I'm
not sure you're gonna have to watch the
movie okay one song you're most excited
to sing of course part of your world
that's my favorite